[Music]
in leave me alone news being at all
submitted by all the way from Algeria Oh
where's that none of us knows
[Music]
fundraisers who asked for donations on
the streets of London now face harsh
restrictions why can't they do it at my
grocery store dude do it at my grocery
store please fundraisers why don't they
do GoFundMe like the charity of raising
oh you mean like the Salvation Army
people with the bells during Christmas
the chocolates the kids with the
chocolate C's oh no Mia Khalifa and
Pasadena walking around I forgot what
it's like the ACLU or OAS sounds alright
yeah so this [ __ ] right so we're
walking by me meekly for going by he
goes hey man it goes hey what's up
brothers y'all got some time over like
nine not really well you slow down maybe
I could talk to you dad I think you need
like an introduction pamphlet on how to
do this dude we other way process what
just happened I was like that's always
when I ask like I'm the busiest person
on the whole Oh God you know I can't
right now I actually gotta go do this
thing what's the thing I think living in
LA has made me an ass because I've heard
every single pitch from like oh I'm lost
can you help me get directions to this
place oh wait but do you have a couple
of dollars to like hey do you like
hip-hop there's this one time when this
guy came up goes hey man you like poetry
in my heart I said yes but I said nope
and I wish he read me that pole but he's
gonna ask me for a donation time for
that [ __ ] movie that dude Tokyo he came
up to his Huber's like excuse me sir I'm
from France a same guy and he said
excuse me do you know how to get the
scent San Bernadino God where was it in
Little Tokyo it's the same book he has a
different theme yeah he said he just
came from France
I'm from francais oh my god the tattoo
on his forehead that can't get a job
that says the same [ __ ] yep he's so
drugged out he approached me three times
in one week and he doesn't even remember
that's crazy dude yeah I had a guy I'm
always I'm always at a grocery store or
going into a grocery store and a guy is
like trying to get me to buy his rap CD
or whatever and one time I was straight
up he's like hey man you wanna you know
you wanna buy my CD and I was like sorry
man I can't listen to music
what do you mean like Mike dude
and the guy look there's a whole bunch
of people trying to get you to sign [ __ ]
if friends I have a video footage
because I was gonna record long [ __ ] but
I didn't release it cuz I don't want to
but basically Merrill was recording me
and as I'm talking to the camera they
walks out she goes would you like to
help orphans and I was like what is this
for I was like I don't know what she
goes orphans do you want to help them or
not that's what she said to me and learn
English is [ __ ] fantastic have a lot
of attitude in it right then I was like
he goes money I was like no yeah and
then there's this park that we walked
through there was like literally seven
of them and there's lady she was like do
you want to help you are like note baby
she takes her clipboard she goes like
that like just like that you wanna pop
her in the baby no in America that's
assault getting hit with that clipboard
that's true he got jail time the jail
time smacked me with the clipboard like
me mean I've tried to be mad I just
didn't know what the thing like yeah no
I was really I was at a grad gas station
this is why I'm so cynical I was at a
gas station I hand a guy a 20
because he was asking me for money and I
was like here you go man good guys
here's the thing here's the thing it's
one of those things we're opening your
wallet up in front of the dude and all
you have is 20 like here you go what was
like I was caught okay yeah so then I'm
like you know what I'm a [ __ ] good
ass person I gave the man 20 bucks I'm
probably due to the year right now go
new TV show then of course he I'm not
even kidding
as I'm finishing pumping I look over and
he's coming out of the gas station with
a [ __ ] 20 if I course that's it
that's the problem you know what in
Hollywood like back in my club that's
old but uh this is one do that always
walks up and down and you know he'll
like one week he'll say like oh can I
get some money can I get some money and
then I think it's just that that pitched
wasn't working out for him and then the
next week he was just straight over just
walk and he wouldn't even stop looking
in the eye he would just start shouting
can I get some beer can I get some beer
can I get some beer and and that was it
he was just plowed through like the
people he just wouldn't stop one does
not even work for him probably not he
was just just gruntled cuz no one gave
him money I think it's really funny we
can go to the gas station and the guy's
like can I get some money for my car
broke down and you get a toad you look
around this fool doesn't have a car
there's a big where's your car
well he just says cargo - dude you're
like I'll see your car but no you think
it's got to get towed you crazy pills I
just said my car got chopped you're like
hey man I don't see it no I meant that
he's gotta get it towed
don't check out so bad at you oh my god
where's my baby I don't see your baby
lady I just can't believe anyone who
asks for money can't believe any story
that you hear in LA cuz I got what he
was trying to say so I didn't catch that
you kill me there's a coffee man
cuz I'm sorry what we're talking about
here is that in the UK they have these
people with clipboards that are doing
like charity fundraising but they call
them charity muggers or chuggers
chuggers these people or call chuggers
sound like a racial epithet right that's
off scared sounds like a Chinese so this
city Chinese fire man the fundraising
practice but they had opposition's and
so they ended up coming up with some
harsh or rules instead of just banning
them and so with one of the rules is
that they have to these people hop on
one foot operate within these two
designated areas that are approximately
8 by 3 feet and it looks like this I
mean we can't chase you yeah they can't
chase you they have to stay within this
little square or rectangle and so that's
one of the rules and another rule is
that they can only have two people there
at a time the fundraising can only be
allowed two days a week Monday to Sunday
and the two days can't be in a row and
chuggin can only be done between the
hours of 10 a.m. and 4 p.m. and in
December fundraising can only be done
one day a week and then only one
organization can fundraise per day on
behalf of one charity and the
fundraisers must wear branded clothing
and if they step outside of that
rectangle they have to cover up the
clothing or well that's good they're
trying to like control it and make sure
that they're not scam artists well
they're just trying to have the people
that go in these areas have have some
peace because they're saying that they a
lot of these people that they're just
trying to go about their day they feel
like they're running through the
attacking you that's what exactly feels
like that yeah it was like all these
people on both ends just waiting to
light can I talk to you can I talk to
you can you sign us up that's why I love
those [ __ ] painted guys who stand on
those buckets and there's a statue guys
I don't do anything I don't do [ __ ] to
you after the bats and I have like maybe
like a blinking light in their teeth or
something problem giving money if this
well earned yeah there's this guy off
the Alvarado Street sir I always talk
about him mr. pigeon guy puts a bunch of
chips in his beard pigeons fly in and
eat him
I gave him 20 bucks that's cool see
that's why that's a skill that's like
the home alone bird laptop if you guys
go there I'm not sure if he's there
anymore is he would do this I would love
to see him interview he's like I had to
add the tada because people never new in
the show we'll just started sticking
around
yeah I love damn I love Street mimes I
love all that [ __ ] I even like anymore
well you gotta go down to Venice Beach
oh yeah yeah yeah there's all kinds of
[ __ ] down there's different kinds
there's like pop guys now like you saw
him Cisco on the pier they have the bush
man have you seen that the bush man he's
so it has like these leaves and this
branch and he goes into this bush and
try to hide himself so he'll walk by you
just [ __ ] stairs I'm like around him
waiting for him to pick someone and then
you know the crowd will sergeant oh
that's good I like that I mean I like
personally I'd rather see people like
that like entertainers rather than just
people with clipboards trying to just
get I mean the people with clipboards
they're not bums they're just normal
people trying to get
who makes like 35 you're doing that by
the way yeah like I saw some rapport
that's where some journalist did it for
like a certain amount of time he's like
I made 35 a year and the tax IRS was
like oh yeah how much you make like they
found him because of it but but I
personally yeah if you work for I love
that [ __ ]
like I like all those shitty dance crews
to like like shirtless dance crews oh
yeah then they do some cops it's shitty
because it's all accountant that out on
the street with a boom box that you can
barely get my gas kills but it's cool
yeah it's cool some of my friends did
that like in college and all that to get
you know their nervousness out and and
they became winners of a BDC and stuff
like that and now yeah what's a BDC
America's Best Dance Crew oh my bad dude
cuz my look was not oh oh of course my
look was like I don't know [ __ ] about it
yeah yeah but they went off to being
professional dancers and like their
their careers and yeah I just want to
see that pigeon guy going on America's
Got Talent
I really do what else could he do after
one segment well you guys the the thing
in the chips thing and then he also does
it where they just come into his hand
and they'll just eat off of there and
then they'll fly to the other hand do he
I'm telling you this is my guy and I can
do that same show for you there's all
these pigeons you don't got a beard
though what they just stays in the beard
dude you see a documentary where Robin
Williams was swimming with dolphins oh
he has so much body hair is like the
same thing that dolphins getting stuck
in his [ __ ] dude came out of the
water like took marine life it's not the
old Japan again you're at the cove
[Laughter]
starfish and it was funny too cuz you
see him and like you're kind of like
weirded out by the amount of body hear
he has and how and how it's still in the
water you know how it kind of like
[ __ ] hangs like clothes and then you
hear him like a voiceover he's like he's
like the dolphin is one of the most
beautiful creat and you're just like
you better like strange what's up
yeah Riv damn I miss you Robbie will you
ever be Robin I met I met him
are you dead no way I can't say it was a
great story I was working upright
citizens brigade at the as an intern and
he came in and just was like how are you
equipped and that's cool that's cool to
meet him yeah I still got to meet him
now yeah okay would you guys do so bad
and your [ __ ] face he met [ __ ]
Robin Williams thank you food I meet I
met [ __ ] Ryan Higa once yeah we all
we all have I met Adam Sandler Kevin
James and Rob Schneider all together it
doesn't surprise me
yeah they used to eat at our restaurant
all the time that we worked at Rob
Schneider liked it and by the way we
were making fun of him sound like a
couple weeks ago and someone was like
how dare you he's better than you and he
has more money than you I know that
right it's like that's so redundant dad
thanks for logging in to Twitter today
Wow yeah he has more money than you know
[ __ ] look at me I know I hope you guys
enjoy this video for more please
subscribe to our Channel and you can
check out the last video right here
[Music]